hi you're gonna invite me to the games
that my soonish okay switch over I did
invite you I'm not going to invite you
when I do I turn notifications off so I
might just not have seen it I'm getting
over I should always invite you we are
all of my parties after talking the last
episode I discovered well I don't really
discover I just remembered that there
are five chapters per campaign so we're
on three well we're I think we're super
toward the end of three my soul is
shriveled and dead
are you still liking this game more than
five yes okay five begins no you see
here's the thing like I go back and
forth with it
five I want make you paranoid but we're
back on the PIP right you're sure no
we're not I'm glad I glad I didn't trust
you then um here's the thing I liked six
more until we fought a boss for like an
episode and a half and I can't live my
life like that forever so like I got
exhausted wait which Oh Irving or
whatever his name was the dude that Leon
and I need you to try drink yes [ __ ]
don't forget all right oh we lost him
wait Chris is disappointed it was the it
was the fighting of the boss that kept
changing animals for like ever
cool that made me just lose hope in this
game
yeah so I don't want to call myself like
this straight-up fickle mistress but
like is that the term yeah
but I'm over that aspect of it like I
just can't
the first time you try out the fan oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I hit boots in
accra turn yeah you're a play driving
game oh you're supposed to come out of
the turn with the boots tiny stitches oh
you play need for speed yeah why are
they getting so far away cuz you're
losing them like this is as fast as I
can go nah we're catching up that booze
helps
if I shoot them does it no chuckling
right oh we're chasing a DES
oh yeah cuz we want to kill her and Lee
on him we've been chasing a DES almost
as long as we were dealing nice oh [ __ ]
okay that affects us I think you're
shooting civilians
I mean it's given me no reason to
believe that that's bad
why is piers going in oncoming traffic
am I supposed to hit those I don't know
what my job is to shoot these jeeps
everywhere they're chasing her I think
but we don't like Ada I forgot what's
going on just these guys have guns and
shooting at me I'd appreciate if you
could kill them but I'm working on it
I'm not being sarcastic I'm just trying
to be right about it no I'm just this is
how I respond look whoa cool [ __ ] up
well like when you shoot a car it
doesn't always explode but here we are
engaged non turn oh yeah here's your the
best driver yes
do you
buthe
buthe
we're zeroing in on Ada Wong how many
people did we spend on this is a huge
government undertaking to kill this
stupid woman
objects in mirror do you not overheat
with that guy I guess not
I've been pushing it down they do it I
think so here's another one I was like
shot child zombie start shooting out the
back of Honda Odysseys it wouldn't shock
me
I wouldn't even blink
god they're so cool but are they always
this way around the railroad tracks SiC
this field
oh [ __ ] whoops what did know nothing
nothing everything is fine okay good
booth [ __ ] I've like intensively done
nothing we're last finding that wall
hard
I've done nothing greatest escape
tract Ada Wong why am I going so slow
oh she's in the park
okay quiet Shh I am stop shooting
she doesn't know where we are if I keep
shooting
it's gonna go okay clarify for people
have not played this game I have full
control of driving like this is not I
mean it's on Rails like that's on Rails
now Wow oh shoot them anything oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] what what
I don't know the amount of control I
have it's dauntingly sad wait why you
not shoot don't shoot guys know right
but I do it I don't know
are you not shooting I'm bit confused I
thought I had a grenade launcher maybe
like what you got the machine gun but I
can see you so it's really confusing
yes love to pick up
like one of those should really be the
end of us
focus on the guys live right yeah I
can't get the guy on the left you gotta
get him Oh sick zombies have their
licenses is it
zombies rule with no I don't foul where
am I going I was just saying if I was
gonna make a license plate for my car it
would have no vowels let me turn that
down a tiny bit
maybe it's the headphones I cellphone no
I mean to be for the machine gun I've
been shooting this machine gun for
really long time so long boys ciao so
you're driving now I'd say yeah you're
driving but why cuz Chris is [ __ ]
awesome
oh good do you think piers could do that
no nice job Chris
he's drunk again yeah that would make
this whole thing in super high shut
punched out of wow I see what you mean
now this is a super loose shooting
somebody check the lost and found I just
lost a turret out of my butt
so should I be shooting see the [ __ ]
swap I got hit by a grenade Grenada yeah
that's cool yeah you need Oh Oh what you
ran over that guy okay kill him blue
bunch of dude this is really loose
aiming I see what you mean now
sorry / ah sorry Wow woo
I'm totally adjusted to trying to
validate my evil oh I like hitting
people with the car but it's not worth
how long the sequences you lose that
[ __ ] not a turn god dammit Mike's is
called resume stop trying to boost on a
tear I'm not driving this is you've
learned nothing
the show is called Rio oh my god I hate
okay in real life too to vent for a
second I hate when on ramps are that
long and you're just constantly beating
into the side of the car especially here
in the middle and the back seats the
[ __ ] horse listen I got a lot of
these are a few of my least I got a lot
of rockets coming after me here
[Music]
hey hi hello there what are you guys
doing Wow
again z-tech again one rocket should do
the trick here our piers and Chris
oh oh where are we
we're sewing Hong Kong we're on a bridge
for Shanghai let me know if you need you
lose that [ __ ] oh my god
shoot shoot him stop running into them
look at our health on the cart oh yeah
to be fair most that's probably my doing
are you saying hitting the cars hurts
our home I don't understand that here we
go
airfield whoa my aircraft carrier did we
expect that to happen just the thing is
biceps cushion the fall as planned
hi boys next stop Bahamas Oh sick end of
the chapter we got two more to go yay
once up closer resonable seven trophy
for that what row fee would say after
her no wait I almost quit the game again
yeah I don't do that well alright so
here we go I'm gonna do fire power so
wait it's getting stuff right yeah okay
so great firearm level all right here we
go quick reload defense all right so we
want getting stuff right okay drop I
believe item drop increase which I
already have but also a firearm power so
you used less
animation fewer bollocks less ammunition
wait hi actually that actually was not
that boring of a level maybe because
we've been doing the same thing over and
over in this game so far
what do you mean I just driving was a
breath of fresh air not it's not I don't
think it fits well in the game but it
was just nice to not be Pearce heard on
peers feet for a second it broke the
monotony of this game
agree with me you're right thank you
okay defense level two quick reload fire
I'm level two you all right I'm fine
quick reload I'm gonna go I don't feel
great about it but I'm not gonna do
anything about it either quick okay I am
drop increase firearm I should be good
cool back ready back I don't know what
is it now you press options okay nut
clusters probably for the best we
shouldn't Mike
you're not being a shill for cashew
crunch wait what's the company I don't
care this joke has run its course what
the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I have
a quick touch oh I almost [ __ ] that up
why did they give me a goddamn QuickTime
event I'll tell you what what are these
things
they have grenades in their jowls is
this okay there's a guy right here all
right let me what Oh
sniper rifle which I don't need actually
I'm coming for you he's mutant oh my god
it's a larva oh okay they explode when
you kill them yeah thank you for finding
out for the hard way yeah you're welcome
hey did you get this whatever this is
ton of sniper rifle angle no I need to
go there's a lot of sniper well for me
I'm coming
oh so this uses different night that's
the NATO that's not the sniper rifle
right it's for the semi-auto sniper
rifle that we just picked up it up
listen yeah you got one now you can use
it I'm gonna go upstairs you want
sniping from here okay I will what's up
distract them with your body oh [ __ ] it
hey guys look at this
tush how do i zoom in click the right
stick I believe if you
yeah what hey guys check out the
world-class dumper on this boy
check out this recoil Oh No
I hope you like die oh [ __ ] keep
distracting them with your sensual buns
hey check out this poop cutter that's
such a hard out bad turn gross things
have changed
how so well there's like 20 now I see
him I'm running away okay I got one I'm
above you
they're like weird maggot things I can't
see him turn into a bug you gross thing
holy [ __ ]
okay I'm out of there oh I see why me
catwalks not helping me show me your
face [ __ ] show me your face oh that
sounds sick I can combine some herbs
yeah 40 minutes closed for help
yeah you ever been able on if you want
to use that oh [ __ ] there's a bug oh you
are so gross get away from it it's
exploding I got some needs there's a
laser on your face see I'm using it as
it oh oh god piers is so [ __ ] cool
but is he always that cool here we go
hard to know where they are
follow the lasers you've activated the
lasers the lasers are you killed another
one Nicole's you're doing a better job
than me yeah [ __ ] did you get no here's
fine feel like you got shot I saw you
kill him yeah but he was really close
I'm really good at killing close ones
well there's no way to study my email or
I have not [ __ ] yeah it's so I'm going
little checkpoint why is that helicopter
starting look at this jamoke
oh there they have swords now and
they're running at it let her get away
what let's go for that objective maybe
if I got one [ __ ] shaky ass let's go
to the right side slide that's a nice
touch you guys want to be my push yeah
you want to see my push guys check these
check this Trisha let me see them saggy
buns but yet firm okay go through this
door screw that up I'm going quick over
here man you can just run no regrets
yeah I have regrets no kill him
oh my god he mutated okay
[Music]
I'm hotter than you bunch of buds thank
god this [ __ ] why are you why is your
knife out on that run why was that your
weapon of choice for that suicide it's
like more aerodynamics I'm faster oh
there's a boat Oh God let's go for it
up the stairs oh sweet so a spotlight
it's bad news what do you mean yeah if
they could see us in the spa they can
shoot us with their gun got it I
understand it's focused on me though for
sure
which is helpful for a year yeah thanks
I don't even know if we should bother
shooting oh it's another whole boat I
thought it was like a couple speed boats
this boat is connected to another boat
oh it's such a slog like why did they
make it this big the game are this
aircraft oh okay
well a because it's an aircraft carrier
and B they should have stopped when they
were ahead with this game oh sweet we're
at the lever great now he's got to go
back down
what's toppings
let's get that book head open we'll
figure something out that's our job
you and I have a mission to complete all
right quit complaining my god when this
game is really bad
shut up corporal hey let's launch of be
a rocket there are also like 30 tanks in
here that we could use okay pour that
over here [ __ ] I'm gonna kick this
ladder down I'll be right come over to
where I am now help you I'm going Slayer
no I mean I'm fine I just they're
[ __ ] gross bug men and then they run
they like run towards you yeah with
their gross little bug body ladder
well you are a gross bug uh here we go
are you having a good time no all right
take a ladder down over here cool you're
doing a great job you just keep doing
that
what's that oh [ __ ]
don't shoot at me from different angles
it's alright I'm going toward that
objective marker you hold down the [ __ ]
ah gross that sounded really nice all
right long since the jaga mark I think
you should stay oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
what should I do stay over that way I
think I'm gonna like press something for
you
cool ok [ __ ] you just die it's not
mutating why can't we mutate when we die
I guess we're immortal that's something
what you need me do you need my
assistance No thank you captain look at
you whoa the stewed suit just came off
and then he mutated what's he doing like
he got super nakey yeah no what is
happening coming Zeke dead I hope do you
need my outfit no he's not
there's like a hundred of them coming up
the stairs sick bring it on
all right I got a grenade that was
really cool this guy's still not done
girlie he became one of them shot you in
your butt get shot in your saggy buns
[ __ ]
yeah that's a toilet it's a sick Cool
Runnings deep cut the bobsled gentleman
is an intricate machine yeah so it's a
toilet I haven't seen Cool Runnings so
la vie but that line always stuck with
me sounds a toilet what are we doing
good question Oh press circle bye bye
yeah toilet cha oh sure um oh I see
it's like Harry Potter yum-yum-yum yes
you okay no we're in a [ __ ] nightmare
here hey you guys have like router
shields
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
use my nater washer
[ __ ] all right
I'm up here doing my thing they're
trying to these guys are with you all
right I'm running to the objective
marker assuming no other guys falls on
the ceiling uh-huh doing some sweet like
maneuver out maneuvering I'm at the
rocket sir oh [ __ ]
hey yeah wow it's going slow company by
from there buddy chance no launching
rocket watch the check this out check
this out
look over here wait hold on can you wait
oh you need to do it too I think what do
you mean [ __ ]
he I'll save ya okay he's dead he's dead
don't throw that Oh
so why didn't that work do you have to
do something over there as well I don't
know so I'm pointing the rocket at that
yeah keep running to the end of that
catwalk I'm gonna take a left up here
maybe I need to like be farther there so
I'm aim at the door maybe you just need
to yeah I love you shimmy on over here
Chris you've got it big baby that's my
nickname for you
are you serious somebody I don't know
shoot him don't worry [ __ ] oh you
[ __ ] did not I got him I got him now
you know I have no health if I get shot
again I'm dead hey there's there's a few
people that was my favorite
now I know I should not be pointing the
rocket yet this is so stupid
here's you uh tell me I don't I have to
do this again
yeah when we obviously Chris see Chris
this Gibson flashbang remember you got a
grenade launcher oh I remember
[ __ ] off
Oh Bruce
just annihilating these [ __ ] oh no it's
that big guy I'll get to the other side
dress
Oh snake is that there's one more guy in
my side that I should kill you do you
need my assistance now yeah just start
shimmying over and I'll try to cover you
better this time
uh-huh just do it fast yeah go jihad
yeah yeah I see him I see both of them
Oh a lot of them well should I have like
no you're good just keep going here they
come
I got him pinned I got him pinned ow I
wish I could do some kind of like okay
there are too many serpentine do you
know a serpentine is yeah it's when you
make a straight line no no no weed is on
purpose all right should be there I'm
not gonna worry about watch your six
flashback hey die yuppie scum can you
get that sniper by any chance I know
these guys oh wait you're in my way
sorry
he's gonna vlog okay so he's hatching
into a huge dude I think oh [ __ ] no he's
pooping another human out he is here
Rose shoot that weak spot I'm back are
you doing I was gonna stab him I hope
you like feet
[Music]
yeah bucket we punch done shirk okay so
you're gonna do that and then do I press
the launch thing or something
it looks like I'm on vacation all right
oh [ __ ] do I press something now yeah
hmm oh [ __ ] do the thing on it
oh that's cute really they couldn't have
beckoned it's blown over that second
door to sweetness put on this letter ate
a one long [ __ ] I just climbed back up
on accident hey I'm back
don't mind me jump you're cute but
you're dumb what come on
what fighter-jet about to shoot at us
I'm assuming if there's someone in there
yeah I'm with you Chris
what in the [ __ ] is with I immediately
got knocked down
okay sprint go this way maybe put this
chin up yep
get some health in your I already have
something just just sprint past it yeah
don't even worry about that
missing the oblems oh [ __ ]
dead end sorry I have steered us astray
run run I'm not gonna lock up pens on it
it did a better job okay fine
tap l randomly we're almost there
there go that way
swimmingly compared to what I thought it
would yeah I thought we would have died
by now
the Jets still know where we are oh I
guess it's the guy in the jet am I going
up these stairs yeah I'll cover you okay
they showed us an auntie
mirabela a text for me she doesn't I was
joking [ __ ] go you [ __ ]
bears could have done it yourself Chris
I like the one that was like a gape like
the actual fence was open why does the
urban it's been five don't worry just be
coming over this way a little bit so
you're like off-screen yes everyone else
not all the way up to what it is today
but starting tomorrow
it's stop with the product placement i I
know nothing about these advertisements
she's doing okay go
is there any I'm not sure the rush was
oh there's nothing else to do in this
room besides to leave it then why not
end it there
what was that is it just me or is this
campaign feel longer than Leon Oh
evidently do you think like they had a
playtester that was like really stoked
on this big series and with like Skye's
games like pretty yeah it's pretty rough
like shut up Marty just finish your play
test
wait what are you saying do you think
they ignored oh it's the real lady yeah
cause like she's wearing something
different you [ __ ] look it she's
wearing different outfits [ __ ]
getting weird either you're so annoying
go go go it's like look oh [ __ ]
I made it wait did you know but I mean I
should have Meili
smashing heads and rocking bed good yeah
I know
that's came up with ocean spider dudes
with gas masks hey I got a chicken
dinner a solo chicken dinner earlier
today in club G my second solo every
like 12 to 13 chicken dinner totally hey
I got a grenade with your name on it but
damn it you beat me to it
Hey well that was overkill keep saying
the things that you're gonna do before
you all we both shot in that time kind
of like
telegraphing every move I made although
I would say holding a grenade launcher
kind of gives away the fact that you
want to shoot them of a grenade launcher
oh no no I want to pick up these a C
round
how do we oh [ __ ] didn't mean to use
that all right whatever
well you're fully healed get rid of like
can you get rid of go down give any seep
or anything you give it up those flash
bangs I would say all four of them
uh-huh see it help don't waste those why
did you I don't know I gotta cut off
that burst no yes
hi know they disappeared cuz of time
share that sucks let's go
excelsior fogging game
hey what's in here punishing me for
being my oh this guy's taking a shower
what yeah there's a guy in the shower
I'm hurrying ring like that now but I
gave him some Old Spice if you know what
it mean there's a herb right here shot
oh not so fun when you're on the
receiving end
she
now turnarounds oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
die die please please die right now
explode yeah he's bloated god damn it
what there's just more acid rounds and I
really want foam oh I got them how do I
switch those here we go
oh I've ice rounds to [ __ ] like I feel
like I want the sniper I want I want
everything I have I've iced remember ice
rounds from resonable three that was
like one of the better items my life is
so hard
yes acid that's regular theory to
anything do I have ice oh I don't have
ice rounds bastard fine okay let's go
mello Yello rounds yes oh you're dead oh
hey how you doing hey you're busted
oh [ __ ] he hit me with his giant hands
Zoey
I'm gotcha sorry okay
what's our next move captain reloading
all my [ __ ] guns wrong this way is
anything over there worth getting an ax
some ammo no the answer is no what's in
here Oh bonus points
Harry I've reached the top coming in
aren't you wear any shoes how the hell'd
you look like a chicken
she's just sauntering she's so smart and
drooping smug Wow don't know what that
was
how's my grenade mmm okay oh [ __ ] yeah
they're ugly under those masks whatever
those masks hey hey I hope you like
dying yeah
welcome to hell two hotties beating on
you hope you like do a body's beating on
you
two sexy men just doing sexy man things
killing lots of guys with their muscles
Wow three guys I see four guns I think
we should grenade them you [ __ ] okay
fine
yeah the way good [ __ ] I can't get
through okay I've got an idea
I'm just gonna do it hey what's up
[ __ ]
okay I'm out deal them yourself that
could have gone better
I hate 81 no Reds what a pile of trash
don't want any more flashbangs hey I'm
reloaded every gun is reloaded think I'm
good - good nice
that's off that
stop sauntering she's just [ __ ]
strolling about this entire game is deja
vu because every time something happens
it happens like more time should we be
worried about those flies yeah probably
oh it's a shadow man shoot that locust
thing in the middle okay cam try I'm
trying to snipe these bugs
what a gorgeous night for some romance
obviously just figure that out Chris
damn it she's just sauntering damn it
she's enjoying every second of this I
don't even think she's scared
I have eased or spring-loaded hey what
did you should hit it with are you
sniping I see that's from close range
it's my new thing oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] I still have my way to overpowered
railgun of a sniper cannon hey [ __ ] I
need help
yeah I got you me and my grenade
launcher it's not not going well for me
here
Merry Christmas happy news
don't worry I'll cover you
okay I guess I will Cedars just making
decisions for me yeah bugs I can see
them do something oh you just jumped on
me oh he's above you
he's on [ __ ] the door just closed again
let's go let's go run away
[ __ ] you bonus points
bone ass emblem oh [ __ ] Anja
ooh they're gonna have lot of ammo
probably some sort of dumb boss fight
yeah there's another plant here but I
can't [ __ ] pick it up I don't even
know what to do about this wait all
these goddamn weapon sweet okay let's go
I'm good you are watchi you by
Alcoholics Anonymous oh what's wrong I
just can't pick up that [ __ ] plant it
appears just shooter it's a different
ADA stop changing clothes shooter in the
new cap even after losing all your men
again
with your track record I gotta say I'd
hate to be a member of your team don't
listen to her captain
where are my manners I mean really I
should be thanking you for being such
good hmm
does anyone else feel a draft on their
chest ever since Adonia you can shoot a
toe or a knee or like this isn't about
vengeance it's about justice it's over
ADA overrated
you're right it is the aircraft carrier
is preparing for lunch and a dead will
flood the streets deja vu boys raccoon
revisited this time
here's wasn't that one-city raccoon said
he was he it'll be the whole world
it's mantis toboggan oh [ __ ]
oh my god well played they came out of
nowhere on a helicopter shot her in the
stomach they shot her in the chest it
have been fortunate her dress had no
armor there Oh what just happened what
more can we explain to you okay came out
of nowhere on a helo shot her straight
in the center of her body this looks
like a different strain there are two
missing what does that happen just take
what's left we'll bring it back to you
all that effort for like a half a second
salute leader
hey no [ __ ] it's been compromised since
six hours out of it the terrorist
assault was just a diversion the real
attack will spread the virus globally
globally like across the continent let's
check the rear hanger they've got to be
some planes back there sir what about
New Zealand that's what my mommy Liv
what about Antarctica
everywhere what about Germany everywhere
telling the truth the entire universe
wait so does that include Earth
what about Mars yeah we get Thanks well
it's too late to talk about it now
all right use a jet stop to just launch
are we gonna play it oh wait is there a
mob there there's a box shotgun rounds
not be naughty
we need three pounds we better go find
him fast thanks Chris one right here
passcode a secured good job oh well at
least she had a coat
Wow
he's dead check it pulp [ __ ] in the
mouth to death
oh it's regenerator remember these like
guillermo del toro 4 and 5 I guess
they're so Pina si I just hate it I
remember the day you were conceived like
it was ten seconds ago why we named you
aircraft carrier because that's where
you were made what are we doing I don't
know so I don't actually know because he
just regenerated now there's four of
them flames
I'm just gonna go alright there's still
twitching I know yeah just go we have to
turn this [ __ ] off stop being gross they
probably came from these toilets yeah
toilet perfect sweet I'll just fire
survived the attack okay
just shoot it I guess [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my
god oh my god help me okay I'm coming
this [ __ ] hand off me Wow his hands
right here Hey there you are you okay
give up the other side of this others
ammo over here
looks like we're in the mess hall more
like messy hall that it still works [ __ ]
he's chasing us Oh legs
it's like that movie teeth except with
legs take out his legs go oh wait I
found a way back cool he's dead
don't care oh there's grenades for my
over here when is that gonna stop being
amusing to you never
I think I can hear feet
I'm here trying to read that board ears
oh no I can hear it you're gross I hear
it
oh you're by yourself
well one more to find
come my circle you've got it let me just
shoot this thing real fast
come on hiya pal this isn't wait
surprised to see you alright last P how
do we get over that thing oh wait
holy [ __ ] die I mean if you shooting
them up come come this way quick
are you sure well get this em over here
different room yes oh thank you this was
worth it this is a nice bed this is a
nice [ __ ] wait oh my god Mike he's dead
look at how many first aid spray look
amaze he is to see me oh it's a great
captain himself oh I can't believe it's
yeah there's a first dates bring the
bathroom too bad he didn't know that I'm
a saint
maybe just for me now you got it oh damn
it
vending machines grab life oh that
scared me
where's this last key am I going the
right way
I don't know turn this you cover me okay
there's some arms
holy [ __ ] a rule that's cruel
hope you like explosions in your mouth
it's like he's alive still raise your
hand none of you but I like it here
nothing what's yet [ __ ]
oh there's another one yeah Wow both
sorry okay
wait he's dead he's not no met to die
backwards
I'm gonna say these grenades actually
because I feel like I'm gonna need them
oh my god what's over this way he's dead
come down this I'm not sure where you
are oh wow what is where's the noise
coming from huh looks like we're on the
right way for the key I've never been in
water before so I feel like this is the
right move 20 meters away I think around
us something kept old home anything
worthwhile
now the bunks nothing howdy nothing what
the [ __ ] that's really weird you'd think
they'd hide at least one emblem in here
no there's another bunk right here oh
and he's probably not dead oh look at
this guy look at this guy
I'm coming if he comes alive now after I
just shot him is he gonna grab me oh
there's a pass go got a tick back did
not realize we were there okay let's go
what's across the hall sorry Jesus crepe
what's that noise I don't know how we're
missing a bunch of bunk rooms bonus
points
one more room daddy's home
this musics pretty scary yeah whose game
isn't oh man we're almost a resonable
seven and by that I mean you are
you've got damn sons of [ __ ] away
there's two more rooms we in check
I just want these acid rounds oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
they've come nom no regrets no regrets
hey I'm coming no in care I'm just gonna
leave them in there oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
there's law behind us keep going keep
going keep going
there's a bunch let's go just go okay
where we go in back to the keycard door
okay yep
anything in here and work well know what
we already been in there ah steam
they're coming
gotta go this way come on it's your left
thank you
don't make me input them individually
well great
I do all right
I'm gonna do do my best to protect you
never mind it didn't didn't come to that
keep going Sarah AI is so dumb do you
mean right behind you as an I'm right
behind your check right
okay oh okay
Circle Circle Circle right expedite this
process it's [ __ ] like they're the
Chris I figured something else
Oh enemies don't hurt us if we oh [ __ ]
oh I do not have the best gun equipped
right now Ivan Han Han oh nice
it's like The Terminator room well what
a double whammy
sinking down here hand double hand sweet
next time I'm not gonna have a sniper
rifle right now I have a lot of young
pmo actually
there might be something I'm gonna use a
jet what a weird room this for sex
that's our sex corner where this jet
three-two-one jet man who's steering Ada
Wong she's like just kidding boys
[Music]
set the chap know we probably got to do
one more thing
finish the chapter and then call it an
episode what is HQ me who's Harry
quartet craft artillery take out those
guns oppa we're playing against an
entire carrier is that even so
impossible yeah yeah hey piers how's
your a never better captain
we're going out the way we came in
captain are you steering what I do it
I'm shooting oh I am sorry
I'm watching this like I guess well
launch yeah but there's no like feedback
on my controller so doesn't feel like
this is Dom it's just like a [ __ ]
ac-130
except not instead
oh sorry are you steering yeah Wow I
just curious I know how much don't
follow we have here not a lot hey hey
hey I got it I guess you are steering
what what are you trying to say exactly
what what are you trying to say
what does that mean
got it what what do you mean by that
what do you change your yaw your pitch
is off okay quick quick quick
I'm doing a shot something this [ __ ]
Joker this jamoke where's my key okay
let's just sprint right at it don't
worry about gonna go all right I don't
know we got into an aircraft to take out
anti-aircraft guns and now we're getting
out once they're destroyed why don't we
just shoot the [ __ ] missile with a
what oh you're still in the gym what am
i doing oh you're just shooting dudes
while I run to the [ __ ] missile
I'll cover those buns I've got a quick
sign event to do my tush is getting hot
ma'am sir all right got it
cool run and jump wow you didn't run
really far away that was c4 you might as
well just stared right at it okay going
to the next one
oh no there's a [ __ ] dude watch out
all right yeah
we're dealing oh I thought you're
shooting joking and shooting at me all
right I'm coming up to your joke is that
another one got it
I'm in they rerouted me to Belgium but I
think I can bypass it oh my god kill
these my Berkeley's alright I just don't
know where they are
yeah he got me well I just don't you
yeah up there thank you
I see some yeah you're not hitting the
sniper he keeps shooting me like that
higher up on the catwalk on the catwalk
know it see the laser
he's right on the corner up there yes
right there yes I see em there's another
guy right next to me another guy right
next to me for another guy redneck
alright shoot him
oh my god there's a lot this isn't gonna
work I'm working on it
alright yeah we have two minutes less
than that I'm shooting all that buggers
gonna explore my god are you alive
barely
max Pierce I got one more to do
is there a [ __ ] sniper
it's really hard to Scott it okay this
next one we do not have a lot of time
get behind anything
um what not you others you look the
aircraft carriers but oh shoot that
thing please why is the timer still
going seriously
okay I've got another one to do right up
here cool I'm there
you owe me to shoot this thing yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah one more got it oh [ __ ]
what you a 55 seconds just shoot the
missile and blow air carriers solving
everything what's up here killing three
birds with one stone
why didn't kill him please kill Pierre
oh my god at the climbers cream
run run run run run Finn's gonna hit me
run run please don't hit me oh this
gonna be so [ __ ] bad-ass jump god god
that was cool
cool God piers is a legend is he gonna
touch that
[Music]
yeah why didn't we do that in the first
place idiots like I'm gonna destroy the
area okay he's in the way I should be
like shoot it now oh [ __ ] he's in the
way I don't what do you mean no no no
you're fine you're fine
got it I had to it takes like five
seconds a lock-on oh [ __ ] wait did they
get one off oh we get to chase this
yes it's in for the city [ __ ] hey he was
in res evil to be on where are you I'm
inside the missile things have not gone
according to plan the call is coding fit
inside the missiles this is uh yeah the
originals of his limo escapes yeah like
we lose so Chris and beers could have
saved us like a - two chapters yet damn
Chris [ __ ] sucks and that's you
I'm not great
by
[Music]
the president we've already seen this it
was literally in the first part of the
game no no no no good
this is toward the end of Leone's it
doesn't matter we already stood it
[Music]
[Applause]
this game is grim
[Applause]
and you really pay attention to it
she's not often
yeah it's Tuttle
end of chapter 4 yes yes really
things just got back
listen I need you to rescue - hi Blaine
only one agent Cheri Burcham
and Jake Muller oh [ __ ] Albert Wesker
suck Wesker Chris he's got antibodies
for the C virus
I got it on my way ah world why not
don't let the zombies bite you I have
herpes why didn't you wait till after to
tell him [ __ ]
sherry and Jack needs you don't let him
down did we let a missile babysit we did
we we dropped the ball on that one end
of chapter four back now we go to the
underwater thing
good job fun I won't call that episode
oh yeah I think well maybe we'll do a
long finale for six hour and a half I'd
say we got till the end of the game yeah
cuz I gotta go I go to Long Beach and
then I go immediately to Australia for
two weeks I'm going to be gone for three
weeks and I want [ __ ] finish this
poorly so today when we're recording
this is what do you leave I leave like
next Wednesday so I was like thinking if
we do two this week we can do it but
anyway we'll be back with I think this
was the penultimate prez equals six I
want to get to the next game so badly so
it's so good that myself and a lot of
other people keep saying like alright
while you're thinking about Game of the
Year discussions remember resonable
seven came out this year because it's
that good yeah could you forget cuz it's
in January yeah that Nier automata came
out earlier in the year culinary isin
was holiday all the nights really really
good everyone
yeah cool alright job you guys okay
this episode of knievel brought to you
by Stumptown i don't think you're
refreshing brews really